what's up everybody i am on tour and i
got a lot of new cities so hear me out
right now i want to see you guys
right now uh we are playing west palm
beach improv this weekend we added a
fourth show on sunday uh that is on sale
right this second also
right now pre-sale as of right this
second for san diego los angeles
burlington vermont uh a second show
added to foxwoods connecticut detroit
pittsburgh albany madison chicago i'm
coming to your city all those tickets
are on sale right now in pre-sale on my
website at salvocanocomedy.com
use promo code god bless one word and
then after that me and christy d will be
in dallas san antonio houston st louis
columbus and cincinnati the week after
christmas and des moines indianapolis
cleveland
uh
washington dc all of you guys on sale
already right now at savocanocomedy.com
it's gonna be great come i'll kiss you
on the lips god bless
[Music]
[Applause]
oh we heard the cry yes i didn't realize
they existed someone blew i mean i
thought they existed but not little like
somebody else i knew they existed but i
never thought to buy them
i don't really love them around but yes
nothing's gonna nothing dude nothing's
gonna change my love for you you just
moved on four corners road
that's it that's it there will never be
another tuck that's it there will never
you guys who didn't like me obsessing
over the tux you'll never get it back
that's it now you're gonna miss it
because it's gone because it's gone well
maybe i was gonna say maybe one of the
episodes we'll do we'll just uh we'll
it'll be uh corners like you can't
imagine yeah yeah corners all day every
day yeah i i um first of all i wanna uh
i had this morning shout out to donato
my buddy donato who got me three pillows
for my birthday i saw this i will mike
that mike that's absurd
i saw i was here i witnessed donato
giving you these pillows and the joy and
laughter you had while you were drunk in
the kitchen at 3 p.m
right before we went to the halloween
parade that's right that was on old
hallows eve yes see everybody see a
couple of things by the way shout out
our fans shout out us being silly is two
things happen one we were very confused
as to why nobody was wearing costumes at
our durham north carolina show because
we realized that episode came out after
durham north carolina so the people who
went to the durham north carolina show
were probably like i would have worn a
costume had i known secondly we also
said on the podcast that we were going
to be wearing mr robot costumes
and at the halloween parade so there
might have been people looking for mr
robots but instead we wore batman that's
right so we did a lot of switcheroos and
apologized we did a switcheroo so we had
said on the podcast everyone coming to
the dorm
dorm show on 10 29 wear costumes we're
like wear them it'll be crazy we'll pull
you up on stage we'll have a contest
right yeah so we go out in dorm yes
couple thousand people we get out there
at the end of the show we turn up the
lights and we're like let's get these
costumes on stage yes and
one like one girl was in like a like a
robin mask yeah yeah like it was like
nobody had one one person was there
wearing antlers nobody cared out of 2
000 people so we're like so we turn our
lights we're like all right let's see
those costumes yeah and then everybody
just like kind of was like looking at us
and i'm like oh if you're wearing a
costume stand up yeah and then like
four people maybe three people out of
now maybe 2 000
and they weren't even like all out
costumes it was like like i said it was
it was nothing right it was like an
afterthought like those are just
probably just fun people
we didn't realize though right we just
we were like all right i guess this is
not gonna work this big this costume
thing we had planned here's the only way
to rectify it why not because we're
co-headlining together december 26 27 28
29 30 and 31 in texas missouri and ohio
why don't we pick one of those shows or
or should we just ask all five oh if
you're coming to any of those shows yeah
wear a costume how about everyone just
comes in santa
why don't we do that
if any you're coming to any one of those
shows whether it be in dallas houston
sugarland texas st louis missouri
cincinnati ohio or columbus ohio
dressed as santa to one of those shows
we will pick the best santa yeah and
bring them on stage that's right and
maybe should we get like a 25 lowe's
gift card or something we're gonna get
him a 25 loves gift card and the best
santa comes up on stage on a chair and
then me and sal will sit on your lap and
we'll tell you what we want for
christmas boom that's what it is so if
you want this has to air before them yes
make sure that this one comes out that
was my fault sorry no but we didn't but
we didn't know we flew home that weekend
like that was wonderful but man they
didn't get on board and then like we
didn't talk to him but then like a week
later pimp's like oh you know the the
episode where you ask them to wear
costumes is coming out this week yeah
and we were on stage going what's going
on here people yeah well like why did
you not come in costume they must have
thought we were lunatics i actually
pushed the island boy one up i just
couldn't help it
it was really you don't want those
honestly i kind of feel like that was an
executive decision you made which we
appreciate because the island boys came
out at the right time the island boys
needed to come out when it came out yeah
because now everyone's all over those
island boys now did you see pimp also
put up to said a video to our group chat
that i want to put on the podcast right
now is the is the little people saying
dressing up as island boys doing it in a
sink yeah which was shout out shout out
to little people who did this who sat in
a sink i mean it was pretty funny i mean
you might people you guys may have seen
this already but i mean this is this
puts our island boy bits to shame
he's trying to make it and this kind of
does look like
me and sal as little people
i love that they're wearing jeans i know
so
shout out
in a sink it's funny yeah shout it out
guys are funny so yeah so um
and yeah babe so so halloween too
first of all i had we got drunk before
we left the house drunk before we left
the house on the ferry i'm going to be
honest with you probably the most fun
i've had in years of anything in my life
really was at that halloween parade
what were there 17 of us 17 walking as
full batman yes and women and babies yes
and people were taking pictures what i
think the funniest thing was is i don't
know if you were too in front but i know
pimp saw this
we had an inn i think one of a friend of
a friend was a police officer working
the correct parade led us in through a
special barricade yeah
17 of the batman yes walked in and then
the officer said you cut off that
barricade at that last batman you cut it
off not a single person can be let in
after that slams the barricade after me
i was the 17th batman and then slams the
barricade on award-winning actor leaves
schreiber and his family legitimately
yeah lev schreiber
leave leon schreiber was directly behind
us with his entire family on a bicycle
and got shut out for 17 batman from
staten island
so it was and to see the look on his
face i mean this guy's an academy award
nominee yeah yeah and then i saw him and
i was like oh my god and i told cabba i
was like you got to let him in that's
liam schreiber yeah and they went and
they let him in but they didn't like he
had to like talk him yeah he finally let
him in and then me i'm such a nerd i
watch architectural digest videos on
youtube as we all do yeah and uh he has
uh two
episodes and one is like an open door of
his like his first condo he ever bought
right and i've seen it multiple times
it's like six years old whatever and i
just went up to him like huge fan like
he's like thanks so much and i go i lo
and i had my bat mask on so and i go i
love your architectural digest episode
and what do you say he was like oh wow
that's awesome he's a cool guy later i
know where you live and what it looks
like also a guy i think he's been a
boxer almost his whole life like almost
like borderline could be as good of a
pro he could have been a professional
boxer if not an actor so we'll
absolutely beat the piss out of you if
you ever get in his face he's such a
cool guy yeah ray donovan i know ray
don't but he has it but he's he's very
poisoned he's a lot of composure
because you know he's a smooth talking
fellow because i would have snapped if i
was him you know i mean i get cut off by
17 batman from staten island what was it
was he like e.t why was he on a bicycle
i don't know why he was on a bicycle i
actually don't know why he was on the
bicycle only his family was walking oh
yeah only him only he was on the bicycle
and i always forget he was in scream i
always he's cotton weary i always forget
he's cotton weary i always always always
forget um but it's so funny that people
attach him to screen because unless i'm
forgetting like a sequel that he was in
he was just in like no lines
he was he was in like a video of the
news on the news yes of the police
taking him in in cuffs yeah he was in
like a clip yeah like and but it it was
such people like oh he's in scream but
he's like not really though it was 25
years ago and he was in 10 seconds of it
i think so so i think what's up i'm in
phoenix arizona this thursday to
saturday it's gonna be a hell of a time
then december 17 to the 18th west palm
beach florida then december 26 to the
31st co-headlining with salvo cano we
got texas missouri ohio and then january
chrissy theater starts find your city
all tickets at chrisdcomedy.com
i think that um that likes it was the
most fun i've had dancing throwing
candies into the crowd
having so much fun even joe derosa was
there and i still managed to have fun
that's right even though he was the only
one that didn't show up in the batman
comments let's give him the rosa de rosa
says
first derozan says i don't want to be
batman then he says i don't know why
we're friends with him fine i'll be back
fine i'll be batman
but he only wears the cowl and the cape
with denim jeans and a black t-shirt so
we have 16 batman full blown yeah full
blown air one bat yeah and then he's
he's just hiv positive hiv pies shout
out everyone who's hiv positive god
bless you shout out heart medicine shout
out shout out all that shout out
positivity shout out positivity yeah um
shout out prep so
so um
most fun i've had um marching bands oh
djs the gays know how to parties
the gay community
who throws a better party than the
members of the gay community maybe only
did he maybe diddy yeah that's it did he
knows how to party that's it but
honestly the gay neck and neck gays and
diddies i mean the floats that were
going by
you know mostly gay men
and women were going by the party that
was on that foot we need to
get a float
next year for that parade i'm going to
look into it because i think it's i
think you're allowed to do it as long as
you go through the proper channels
whatever it takes whatever it costs and
we're getting every gay friend we have
on that thing every day batman and the
gays and we'll get left right we'll beat
diddy at his own game 100 and guess
who's coming on lee have schreiber
we'll invite him yeah he'll he'll we'll
tie the float to the to his bike and
he'll cycle us through now one of the
funniest bits one of the funniest bits
that we had here's here's some pictures
for well these are all pimp's photos huh
yeah dude what a fun you documented this
[ __ ] out of here i mean he sent me
within the next day he sent me a dropbox
with 400 photos and i was like oh my god
pimp had a full had a full documentary
ready to go for netflix
the next day and you in full costume you
photographed the whole thing in costume
dude pimp pimp had a uh he filmed ari
shafir peeing into a bottle underneath
his batman suit i mean you filmed ari
committing a crime we should hold that
over ahri's head and blackmail him
because i mean we have evidence that he
urinated in pubs i mean rogan already
played it on his part oh he did all
right so the lord
come on hang out and discuss if he
wanted to he's around yeah um a lot of
we saw a lot of uh covid
needle covert vaccine card costumes
which you know it's i think it's a good
idea in theory but it's it's a little
hack now it's like where we get it
i think 17 batman was original i think
so too i think it was original and i
kept telling the cops we got this yeah
every time we walked past something i'm
like we'll be on the lookout tonight
yeah they all appreciate it they all
appreciate that they all have their
hands on that gun
take one more stop you know you know
what we didn't see we didn't see any
island boys we didn't see any island
boys it's a very good we thought it was
gonna be the thing yeah we didn't see
any island boys um i i got
really drunk too because in our um
little tool belt things we had bottles
of you planned it out we planned it out
right you planned it out right sal does
a great sal plans parties so well and is
so good at partying that i think it
pushes over the line and you are gay i
think there's only a gay brain can do
what you do the party mode in me is is a
gay man um our i will give ari the
credit for the mini bottles in the
utility bill we should fear gay yeah
but we got yeah we had all the candy
ready we had our own uh we had a we met
at a meeting place we all had bat dinner
first you you planned it out you planned
it out great and uh and you're a veteran
you've done it before we attacked the
joker um yes we attacked him he attacked
the joker we found the one blue batman
yeah he was like
sixties back yeah yeah um i i honestly
think like i can't imagine not doing it
again like i it's just something that
like you know i want to constantly do
every year i know i i had done it eight
years running and it's this was the
first time i did it in 10 years wow so
why'd you take 10 years off because
they're too busy with the show yeah i
used to do it at with the bar and
friends from local friends and
everything and now i'm always on the
road and i'm not with that community
anymore and right a lot of people are
just married kids moved away all that
stuff so i needed a good core group but
we got it so next year
we uh
our goal is to to add to it but just by
invite only invite only not like posting
will always be masked it'll never be we
will always be
anonymous anonymous so always being
honest i say next year you know what we
do next year we go is kim kardashian
with the black spandex out oh my god
that's where we go how do you breathe
and see through that we'll find a way
does she really believe that that outfit
a lot of couture fashion like a lot of
the mecca it's not meant to be taken
seriously is that correct
like nobody is really that outfit is not
functional the one where she was zipped
up like a [ __ ] right right like that's
just look at look that's just stirring
the pot and
being relevant and staying in the
conversation and right being like uh you
know an icon who does you know it's like
when lady gaga wore beef yeah yeah it's
just what it's just what it is
but but what but then what do you do you
get in what you do she got in and she
unzipped it before she ate her salad i
guess yeah i guess it's the only i mean
listen i know how hard it was to take a
pee-pee wearing this batman costume i
could imagine when you have a full zip
up spandex suit
you're not peeping very much how is she
breathing and seeing out of that thing
i don't know but i know that that it's
in contention i think for next year's
outfit that's great let's get kim and
pete on the podcast should we get him on
hey babe god yes please um
let's get them on i i think um i think
yeah it was the most fun and then i woke
up the next day as because here's what
it is being catholic is you always know
when there's a lot of positive happening
you always feel like impending doom
because you know you're a sinner and you
whip yourself that's what catholics do
so i woke up the next morning with a 101
degree fever and full pus on the tonsil
strap throat i mean that's right you
guys
no doubt about it strepto 101.5
almost borderline 102 degree fever i
mean woke up with the night of my life
thinking i have a hangover and no sir no
siri bob woke up this morning got
yourself a strip god myself
yeah
yeah i disrupt the cockalocolus have you
ever done the thanksgiving parade i
don't understand it as much i have i
haven't marched in it that's not like
the village one but i i did a
late teens you can't manchester it's
freezing cold but it's it's cool it is
kind of cool you like that one too um i
i you know and ever since then not only
have i not gone again but i'm never up
in time yeah you know what i mean like
should we go this year but i really
actually want to rekindle my
relationship with that parade yeah yeah
because it's i love anything that gets
you in the spirit santa santa's always
at the end of that parade i'm rocking
christmas music now i mean put on now
most people are the neighbors of course
you from my house number one i mean this
is coming out
close to thanksgiving
thanksgiving oh i just rock it i get
when when the holiday season comes i
usually listen to like stern or jazz in
the car i don't listen to radio that's
my whole life right but when the holiday
season comes 106.7 or the oh the holiday
channel is on sirius
boom right in my opinion christmas all
day into our drive christmas instinct
merry christmas and uh uh
mariah carey merry christmas song in my
opinion two best yeah
in sync's one which is merry christmas
happy holidays
because they have one two no it's in
sync it's insane but nkotb has a has a
has a new kids has a a very popular
uh i don't know
i know i'm not sure uh kids on the block
christmas let me see new kids on the
block had a bunch of kids chinese food
makes me sick and i think it's fly when
girls stop by funky funky christmas
funky funky crap that's it gonna have a
funky funky christmas um so so let me
ask you this for thanksgiving by the way
much like batman that night i turned
around and you were gone gone well
because what happened was no you were
you you were like meta yeah i had the
bad thing though the bat signal actually
came as a text from my mother and said
get your ass home your daughter's been
hysterical crying since 6 p.m so we got
never in my life by the way i called
an uber
i'm talking about press you know uber
send it it said finding your ride said
ride found and then gave me the five
minute warning where i i was on the
corner we were on the corner of 17th
street and park avenue or union square
yeah
the the car was on 17th street in union
square it where it just dropped somebody
off and immediately picked me up like
you almost like got it like you're
passing a baton yeah it was in it it was
insane even the uber driver turned
around to us and said i've it's never
happened that quickly that must have
been like when the lottery are getting
hit by lightning because on a night like
on a night like with all the road
closures and everything the road
closures the drunk people no one's
driving they're just a massive amount of
people in the streets the traffic yeah
like we couldn't even i couldn't even
get one late that night for like a half
hour yeah no and it was funny as the
baby was hysterical crying allegedly for
the whole time we were gone
as soon as we walked into the house then
baby violet stopped
looked at jasmine her mother looked
stopped crying my mother gave her the
baby violet immediately threw up all
over jasmine's batman suit no i mean
immediate full projectile bailey that
this uh the stop suit's impenetrable
it's impenetrable yeah so it didn't it
just
violet was sorted voided yeah so she
tried she tried to get us she couldn't
yeah um
so
so yeah and i mean speaking of kids i
mean baby can i just tell you i mean the
night the night i'm coming off of yeah
bubs yeah you look like you got a little
something behind the eyes yeah bubs let
me tell you something yeah was awoken
tell me sweet first of all this is
what's going on in the house right now
yeah we got we got three kids right we
got two adults we got one kid the 11
year old with diarrhea we got the middle
kid six years old with a pus
bubble
infection in her back wisdom tooth
okay then we got the baby the four month
old with a head cold that every time you
put her down in the bassinet to sleep
she thinks she can't breathe screaming
crying throwing her legs up and just
puts one arm up that's just how she
moves two legs up one arm right we have
mom 101 degree fever no right now and we
have me who feels very fat and out of
shape from eating too many bacon egg
cheeses and muffins well don't discount
that though that's that's a real feeling
too absolutely just because just because
you're not wailing and nothing's
actually just because i don't have
diarrhea and pus coming out of my teeth
and a fever doesn't mean i don't feel
bad right exactly don't internalize that
let that out
that's like the diarrhea of feelings
exactly
so we fall finally every but the whole
family gets to sleep it was about 10
o'clock last night whole family gets to
sleep like that like a snap of a finger
1 30 in the morning we got violet
hysterical crying because she feels like
she can't breathe just snarling boogers
coming out we have
delilah the six-year-old run into the
room blood coming out of her mouth like
i was like it almost looked like she ate
one of those like blood capsules you see
in the movie like foaming for the mouth
like i was like is this a joke we have
jasmine get awoken she wakes up she goes
i feel like i just got hit by a truck i
think i have covered i was like perfect
then i'm like okay i can deal with this
then the eleven-year-old tristan myself
diary was too much comes in no
you're like i got this on the controller
he was like
no but it wasn't even that it would no
no it was a situation where it was i i
have diarrhea dripping down my leg oh
wow i mean i got a fully active full
house you're like bob saget yeah i said
boy here we go that's what i said yeah i
said where's the camera in america's
fighting some videos right now you had
blood and diarrhea coming at you blood
diarrhea fevers congestion yeah so wow i
said it was one of those things where i
i just sat up calgon take you away do
you remember that no no no it's an old
ad from when we were younger when i was
younger well done take me away it's like
when you can't handle it anymore yeah i
forgot what calgon is though hit me up
chrissy caligan yeah so i i how did you
what did you do what was your role so it
was one so one of those things because
here's the thing from nature
i don't wanna i don't wanna get i don't
wanna see the calculator i don't wanna
not be able to monetize though it's a no
no i'm not playing the video it's a bath
powder that is about soothing bath
powder which which absolutely have we've
researched has shown gives you cancer so
calgon bath powder probably involved i
would think in many lawsuits because all
types of baby powder now have been like
no bueno you got to buy corn starch not
towel that's what it is yeah you make
that pivot yeah i might get
i if if the other one is that bad for
that long i've been throwing baby powder
on me since i'm a baby honestly i don't
do baby powder anymore and if i don't
have any cornstarch i throw domino sugar
right down there i just throw domino
sugar white powder
whatever it is it's going to be fine
what does that do for you the baby i
don't get it it's just
silky smooth silk smooth so when babies
have a rash or when you have any type of
rash diaper rash or adult rash the baby
powder kind of keeps it um i think it
keeps it it's wrong it keeps you dry
yeah so it smells good so it's true yeah
it's it's it's it's it's uh yeah it's i
think it's really what it does it keeps
you dry so yeah
which i guess every relationship i've
been in every girls just on baby powder
yeah
so
so
um so
so i
don't have issues with johnson and
johnson since before the cove since
before the vaccine i've had problems
with johnson johnson and you know how
you know crazy this even goes deeper
than that
my
grandmother before she dated and married
eventually married my grandfather when
my grandmother was like 16 years old was
allegedly went on a few dates with i
believe
whoever went on to become johnson of van
johnson johnson or the heir to johnson
johnson something with johnson johnson
that my grandmother picked a sanitation
worker over oh my god shout out to
sanitation my dad shout out
but literally it could have been either
the heiress to johnson johnson or that's
not even rich that's wealth wealth yeah
yes she said johnson johnson or let's
live in a three-floor walk-up in queens
so we live in queens right so but now
now who's having the last laugh with all
the johnson and johnson exactly your
grandmother and the sanitation guy
exactly and queen's the borough yeah
because who's picking up the garbage
yeah so i just sat down on the bed and i
said i had to like just take a moment
like because i mean the kids were crying
everybody you know i'm she's like you go
down make the food you're being tested
i'm being tested the devil's working
today i just shut my eyes i just shut my
eyes and i said you know what just take
a moment this is going to be a long
night it's going to be going to a long
day i am going to a long week
so i did heroin just
right right well i called betterhelp.com
hey babe and i was talked into then i
went down and i got some i went to um
america's number one meal kit hello
fresh yeah that calmed me down um so
no so what i did was i said take do one
child at a time who needs the most help
i said you got
one with diarrhea one that can't breathe
one with a bleeding mouth one with 101
degree fever so i think honestly if i
can rank those yeah let me see let me
see how you did it okay okay what would
you do okay your wife is an adult
so i think that first and foremost you
have to concentrate on the kids right so
i would probably slot her
last because she can take care of
herself she has some type of autonomy
that's what i chose but it doesn't matte
i just just just fyi she did i
slaughtered her fourth but i'm still
yeah obviously in the doghouse for that
okay because there was some way she
wanted me to somehow be able to do it
you can't you can't really uh emotions
are different than that she also needs
support sure so you know you can't
really yeah i think the diarrhea has to
come
third
okay you know i mean it's it's no good
it's energy no good you don't want it
around you don't want to be looking at
it smelling touching it none of that
stuff and usually if there's some
there's more on the way right so what i
did with that one fyi is i threw him
right in the shower with his clothes on
all right that's what i did and then
told him to disrobe when he gets just
just wash it off right okay i said
you're 11 years old i put the shower on
just we got it okay but you did that
third or you did that first third oh you
did so far so far you're right okay i
gotta believe that violet is the
youngest yes and it was a breathing
sitch and so i think she needs comfort
depending on if
d
lyla was in excruciating pain or
just bleeding
she was both bleeding and excruciating
pain
so what i did is i went 1a1b i i thought
i was about to say double dude dub dubby
dudes picked up the babes in the arm
picked up the babes gave her a shot of
tylenol with the syringe i was like
doctor quinn i'm sorry what happened
there
with does it that's the way you
administer tylenol these days to the
baby to a four-month-old yeah
with
you put a needle in your baby no not a
needle it's um the syringe but no point
where um you just you just you shoot it
like down a trait shoot it that's it
little by little that's the only way you
kids can't i mean she's four months old
but she sucks on like a bottle
yes but you just okay you just shoot it
i get it now you just basically shoot it
right down the throat you're gonna see
see like that
wow that's how you give it to the base
and you have that on hand you have it on
hand you have to
so
lit her up i gave her that i said you
hit her did you hit her with a double
dose maybe just to calm things down i
gave her 7.5 mls you don't want to [ __ ]
around with tylenol and a baby so i said
you know what we're gonna go 7.5 mls as
the doctor directed um it said it said
if under if under six months stop and
ask the doctor i said i don't have time
to stop and ask a doctor right i'm just
i'm dr quinn medicine woman i'm just
gonna do this correct so
so i got
i i i got her then the last one is
delilah who's literally bleeding from a
tube right so i said i got the order
right though 181b you did yeah so what i
did for her is i gave her some motrin
okay i figured she'll calm down you know
what i had what saved the effin day i
had from the day before it was a little
hardened but i had soft-serve carvel ice
cream in the refrigerator so i put that
in the microwave to thawed that gave her
a full
[Laughter]
you thought it right or you defrosted it
i defrosted it what did i say de-thought
it default
address what the cake was for
the cake we had a carville cake because
tt jerry the night before it passed his
her days road test and it's now a
licensed d-class state of new york
full drive first time ever first time
ever full license like does not need
anyone's permission to drive you know
you feel comfortable in the car with yes
we're actually buying her a car today
buying her a car the funniest part is
right after she passed a road test i was
there chris had a realization that tt is
his teenage daughter yeah she got out of
the car she got out of the road test and
said when are we getting my car yeah
right away so that's why we had carvel
soy so he so so i i nuked that gave her
like pretty much like a milkshake and
that was like a treat but also it was
cold soothing for the dudes so
the holidays are approaching and you may
be thinking about how you're going to
save some extra money well i've got a
solution that maybe i haven't thought of
consolidate your high interest credit
card balances to a lower rate and save
with lightstream
lightstream offers credit card
consolidation loans with rates starting
at 4.98
with auto pay and excellent credit it's
much lower than the national average on
credit card rates which is 19 apr plus
your rate is fixed so as rates continue
to rise yours won't budge
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience and that's exactly what they
deliver just for my listeners just for
alice's now go you're gonna get a
special uh interest rate discount and
save even more
lightstreet.com hey babe that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com slash hey babe you're gonna get
a sweet discount subject to credit
approval rates range from 4.9 apr to
19.99 apr include a point five zero
percent auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply and offer a subject to
change without notice visit
livestream.com for more information
yolanda vega i am yolanda vega this is
probably one of the only days where i'm
not wearing stan socks yeah and stan
socks not sponsor the podcast it is my
favorite sock company of all time i love
stance socks i truly feel the same and
the tip of my hat to the folks over at
stance i got a package with a bunch of
socks in it and i'm just adding it to my
collection thank you so much thank you
so much yeah that socks i love them your
feet don't stink in them i mean
let's
tell you a little about stance stances
premium line of socks apparel apparel
too and more always come correct with
colorful constructions innovative
materials and choice fits that are built
to last that is
totally true and that is a very accurate
sentence throw in an all-star creation
of a-list collaborators and those lucky
recipients on your holiday nice list
have never had it so good look we're all
looking for things to buy right now yes
since it's a cool gift that isn't too
expensive how about bob marley stance
socks i mean i open up bob molly stan
socks for christmas i mean i'm literally
kissing whoever gave me that gift on the
lips 100. i understand what about barbie
i want barbie
kid it's a barbie world i'm a barbie
girl living in here goonies the office
wu-tang tang
is my lawyer yeah i'm gonna wear socks
and jill perkins who's she'll perkins
kill perkins he owns our perk uh
family restaurant all right nice that's
nice uh what stance apparel item do you
like away the most definitely my biggie
socks all right they're soft they're
comfortable and i love them stance has
the perfect gift for every punk and poet
on your list go see for yourself it's
easy just head on over to stance.com
pick out some stylish you think they
might like enjoy the color and comfort
of a life of a life less ordinary with
stains
miraculously somehow they all wound up
falling asleep i wound up getting back
into bed forgot to get the
jasmine her medicine so went down got
that got her two tylenol she popped them
she popped them she
would use i would use a syringe you
would use this right it seems like fun
it's the only way i administer yeah
from now on open up like that so she so
then
so then we fell asleep for a little bit
then we were walking again at six
o'clock in the morning because the
madison wore off now delilah's the lot
literally it looked like in the back of
delilah's mouth a pocket it was almost
like you know like one like at the crust
of a pizza there's like a bubble yeah
that's what she had in her mouth oh
delicious it looked like i know i was
like you look like pizza crust i was
like i want to eat took her to the
doctor took her to the dentist okay
now the thing to make matters worse she
also had a cold
so i didn't know this pediatric dentist
what they do is they give you a little
laughing gas they give a child a little
laughing gasp i got a perfect segue numb
it down they numb it down numb it all
down feel finger you know tingling in
the fingers blah blah blah then they put
a little whatever the novocaine or
whatever new things they use to numb the
mouth yeah and then they rip a tooth out
they have to rip our tooth out okay
because of the cold
the not the uh laughing gas wouldn't get
up to her brain it was blocked by snot
wouldn't get up to her brain blocked by
snot blocked by some story that's our
new album yeah cover block by snap we're
putting a new album blocked by snot um
no novocaine uh no no she couldn't get
the cane couldn't get the cane and then
the dentist said to me he said listen i
can't inject her mouth
with
anything because if she moves the needle
break off like she i need the laughing
gas so she doesn't you know like she
needs to
like okay i can't give her a shot
because we're adults if you put a needle
in my mouth i'm not going to move you
put a needle in six-year-old's mouth
she's going to move she needs to be
jacked up she needs to be she needs to
be laughed she needs to be hysterical
after right because she needs to be like
a freaking hyena you got to be on full
laughing gas it's like you've got to be
it's like you're watching hey vape right
you got to be on laughing gasps yeah you
should have shown her an episode that's
what i said i said should i put on a
babe
and so but um they're russian doctors
not in the mood so so are they ever you
know no never really are they very
knowledgeable great i mean i want to i
forgot what the dentist i don't know if
i've ever heard a russian laugh
no they don't know i think they're just
like that is hysterical yes laughing gas
doesn't work on me but they do a show in
russia the whole crowd is like that is
hysterical that is hysterical they were
coming to moscow babe they um by the way
great dentists i mean literally what
they had to do they take me out you know
they're they're calming her down the
head lady takes me out she goes listen
she goes here's the situation
that lady the head lady the head dental
the head lady at the dentist yeah we see
the dentist she i think so
so she goes imagine i was just in a
mental institution
everybody thought they were dancing the
whole entire thing is a fema dream yeah
she takes me out and she says i mean
this is an exact quote she goes okay
here's the situation laughing guess
isn't working parents want to learn a
week's vacation good yep yep she was
laughing isn't working she goes your
daughter's got an infected pretty bad
infected tooth i'm worried that's
dangerous placement of where it is this
can go into her bone it can lead into
her brain
this tooth she said needed to be out
yesterday she goes so we're going to
have to do is a little frontier medicine
what the hell is this 20 21 i'm on
staten island is that what does that
mean a horse and carriage that's what i
said i said yeah what would do you mean
a oil yeah like what are we talking
about frontier medicine is like do you
want to go
go gather leaves and berries yeah what
are we talking about here yeah she goes
i'm going to have to rip the tooth out
of her head with no
numbing
so it's going to be excreting that legal
who does that russian doctors wow so i
said he's like she's like it will be
hysterical it will be your daughter will
be hysterical hysterical so i said
there's no other way she said there's no
other way this is today this is hours
ago
literally oh my god
what is that like as a parent first of
all
i mean i had to hold her down she was my
daughter was screaming like you can't
imagine i was no no i want to want to be
clear i'm not afraid to admit this fully
hysterical crying oh wow i mean crying
yeah because like like to watch my
little girl like have to go through this
and i was like if that was me i would be
[ __ ] dead like i'd be like i can't do
i walked out of a cleaning two weeks ago
out of a dental cleaning i walked out i
set it on the pod i walked out
and now to get a tooth ripped out in the
back of your head that has a pus bumble
already around it oh it's probably the
nerves it's sensitive oh
oh ripped it out i mean a toothache is
the worst pain right literally to take
something like that and the ankle i had
was from right on top of her right like
so i can see everything was happening
they clamped down on it the doc dentist
had to put her foot on the chair and
yank it out like a movie like and it was
like that like had it up my daughter
screamed and then went limp i thought
that she passed out i genuinely my heart
was like because yeah the surge but then
burst of adrenaline came in gauze pants
bit down bleeding drooling blood
everywhere i'm hysterical crying the
doctor said to me to go you need to go
go outside take a break you need to take
a break this is very traumatizing for
everybody who told you is the head lady
the head lady the dental hygienist had a
tear coming down all right had a full
tear coming down off fry i said to the
dental hygienist when they took my
daughter into another room just to give
her some numbing cream i should have
ever seen anything like that she was
like that was one of the toughest ones
i've ever had to deal with wow she said
nine times out of ten when the kid comes
in with the uh congestion in their nose
we send them we reschedule because we
need them laughing but your daughter had
an abscess an infection that was getting
worse by the minute
that tooth needed to to come out
so then um then uh that we gave her
tylenol we gave her motion the syringes
and honestly as soon as we got home
she was like running around playing i
bought her lol dolls uh uh polly pockets
i went to ride a field day at cvs i went
down that toy aisle and i got her every
toy i i think i might have spent a hunch
on toys from my daughter came back with
flowers 100 cvs is a lot of a lot of
money they got them they got them
b-grade toys then be great toys yeah
that yoghurts carvel we got uber eats
carvel coming i mean we literally i mean
no school today no school tomorrow no
school on the weekend of course i mean
this girl she can have literally queen
of the castle for as long as she wants
if she walked up to in the house gave
you the finger i was like [ __ ] you you
wouldn't even say anything to it i
wouldn't care at all
you know what delilah if you're watching
and we know that you are this is your
chance i do delilah daddy deserves it
i'm telling you literally
never the the trump
i mean listen what my daughter went
through is i can't even imagine so i
know this it's about her but just
you know me i literally traumatized like
you can't imagine to see your daughter
after watching that i don't know if i
can handle that like if i was a cartel
watching which and we know that there
are many drug cartels
especially in some of the some of the
newer cartels popping up really are big
fans thank you we thank you for the
support thank you so much um support is
supporting my highest license
and you know we know you slicing up your
victims whatever it is so so but if i if
you wanted information from me
don't forget about the waterboarding
forget it correct literally just put the
thing in my and say i'm going to rip a
tooth out what do you want to know oh i
thought you were going to say if you
want information from me forget about
waterboarding whatever just god forbid
anyone has my daughter yeah yeah but
then you were like pull twos out of me
no if you just put a clamp on and said
i'm going to rip your i can't even watch
scenes in movies that go that go there
like sometimes they'll cut someone's
finger yeah they'll snap it on backward
or they'll stab someone in the eye or
they'll rip their teeth out or something
or take the pliers and rip i i can never
watch it i always turn away yeah no the
the pain
i think it got to a point for her when
when she went limp a little bit i think
got to a point where her brain was like
i can't process this yeah yeah so just
like blackout pain yeah but i had that
they called that blackout pain for a
reason that blackout pain i have a
couple times i felt one was f i fell
skiing
i didn't i don't ski and i and i it was
late in the day at the end of the day
dusk
i would call dusk approaching it was the
protein dust yeah
and it was getting a little bit um cold
out and so the snow was like kind of
icing over lulu and then
it was new year's eve 2005 into 2006.
wow and uh my friends who all was the
song of the year number one song 2005
and 2016. i have to guess we will pull
it up lord i don't even know
that's like
that's like a time that i don't really
know what like what what was contributed
to music
you know what was the number one song in
2006 show stopper danny kane
oh bringing sexy back justin timberlake
okay there you go okay um
my friends were like it's the last run
of the day come up with us to the higher
mountain
and i
stupidly went with him and it was like a
diamond or a black whatever the black
diamond or whatever the hell jacket jack
of diamonds yeah and uh we were gonna go
down in stages so go down a little stop
go down i'll stop just so and they're
like we'll go first so we'll be waiting
for you so they went down and then the
very first thing i went down and the
only way i know how to stop is to take
your feet and point them inward it's
like almost like plowing it's like i
don't have enough skill to like do it
much else but when you turn them in to
like get snow underneath and to slow
down when it's ice that trick does not
work right
so i went down and it was like you know
maybe
what was it 500 feet that they were
waiting for me and i only gained speed i
only gained there was a body in motion
yeah and i
they were like stop stop and i was like
i can't [ __ ] stop i zipped past them
to the point where i almost couldn't
recognize their faces and then i started
screaming like because then i knew i
wasn't gonna stop until i fell i was
gonna make it down the hill without
falling so i'm like i gotta do something
in and i'm like i don't know what to do
so i'm like leaning my body like trying
to fall down but instead i leaned and i
went i careened right and i was going
right at the pillar that holds the
i was going to sunny bone on myself i
was going right you know did he kill
himself he did
hit a pillar he hit a tree
god bless him shout out sunny bone but
you you think he was going the speed you
were going at he he died i started uh
online gambling this year for football
only i'm dipping a toe i'm new at it
because my friends have been doing it
forever and it's just this i was like
let me try i have been intimidated
because i don't know the sports terms
like parlay and all that yeah yeah
let me tell you let me tell you
i've been listening to the show it's
called bet ql daily first of all it's
hilarious you got this guy joe ostrowski
joe giglio and aaron hawksworth
they serve up this wage entertain this
wagertainment is what i've called it
it's it's it's wagering entertainment
it's almost like watching like
sportscenter but it's like it's all
overweight it gives you all the insight
on like how to how to yeah yeah like
gambling basically
no no nothing she put on we put on pet
ql daily and she was laughing as they
were ripping the teeth out of her head
that's how good the show was you got you
certainly heard of fanduel it's
sponsored by fanduel and it's a must
listen show for sports writers and
sports fans alike uh pretty cool i'm
gonna i'm gonna take a listen to it
because i do do my weekly best i do okay
i do okay but i'm really intrigued 9 a.m
to noon eastern time you can listen
every day weekdays on odyssey spotify or
your favorite podcast app bet ql daily
presented by fanduel it's really
freaking awesome all right let's go what
would you do if you didn't have high
interest loans or credit card debt what
would you do what would i do honestly if
i didn't have high interest loans or
credit card debt i'd probably finally
find happiness you would right i think i
finally find happiness when i've been
searched if i've been on a journey
since the time i'm six seven years old
well chris with upstart you can pay off
your existing debt quickly and easily
and starts living your life really if
you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month it could feel like
your never-ending cycle of debt with no
end in sight we've all been there
upstart can help you make the final
payment so you can go ahead but
it's the final payment
wait a second is this because you just
told me that and i feel like tingling
and numbness
is this happiness
babe am i feeling happiness because of
upstart you're for the potential from
upstart you're starting to feel it in
your loins
is that what the leaking for my penis is
no no no that's not it that is not
upstart okay not only okay you can check
your rate without impacting your credit
score in minutes for loans between 1 000
and 50 000 and rather than looking at
the credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment
and credit history to find out a smarter
rate for your loan okay upstart's a fast
and easy way to pay credit card debt
with a personal loan all online paying
off credit card debts consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses right over a million people
have used upstart to get one fixed
monthly payment with the clear payoff
date okay find out how upstart color
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com hey babe that's
upstart.com
hey babe loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and what was
the other one and certain other
information providing your loan
application upstart.com hey babe right i
was going fast
and then i was heading toward the thing
and i was screaming and people on the
lifts will like drop down drop down i'm
like i freaking can't and then finally i
just took my ski pole and i jabbed it in
front of me
and it broke but it made my body and
then i went fl my one ski went in it
catapulted me the ski came off
catapulted me my whole leg twisted from
the ski
catapulted me in the face i went
airborne slammed down on my face face
first head first slid about another 100
feet
and then i just was completely nearly
unconscious i couldn't move my leg uh
blew up because i twisted it and
sprained it it blew up and i i had just
i was i have a picture of it i have to
find it i i gotta if you remind me i
have a picture of me when my friend slid
down and got to me and i i always took a
picture
i was trying to let them know that how
much i was really in pain because i knew
they were gonna come [ __ ] with me and i
was i think i was almost crying and i
picked my head out of the ground and i
looked up to look at them and i only saw
black
i swear to god i was blinking and i only
saw black and then they like flickered
and then like i kind of saw them i was
the pain could you walk off onto your
own power they had to send this
stretcher for me
oh how embarrassing is that so
embarrassing dude
so they had to send a paramedic with on
a snowmobile yeah with the stretcher
attached to it oh my god so the guy
comes up the mountain right and now he's
got the sirens going everyone now this
lske is a stop being around me and all
the people on the lift are like is he
okay like people ask i'm the big news
now and the guy comes they roll me over
my ankle was blown up and like we got to
put you so they put me in a stretcher on
my back they tell me i have to keep my
hands like this because they don't want
it to go and my hands get like under the
blade like we're going so they say keep
your hands like this they zip me in a
yellow bag and they zip me up to here so
i couldn't move and my legs were
stabilized but it looked like a body bag
and i was laying on my back like this
and i had goggles on and then and then
they like he had to go back down the
mountain through the main area through
the lodge up another mountain to go
where the medical area was so i drove
through the entire resort everybody saw
you and and
i couldn't move i couldn't move my hands
i couldn't talk but somebody was going i
wasn't next to anybody my friend said
we'll meet you there but as i'm driving
through all the families i heard look
away look at my kids are screaming and
everything people were like people like
is he dead is he dead i heard this all
yeah but i was like i was in the coma
they got me up there and i was in like a
10 was like a mash situation i was in
like a tent
and they had to wrap my leg and put it
in like an air cast type of thing and
then i could not walk for days actually
wow they had to bring me back to the
lodge and then in the lodge the entire
night i had to sit on a uh
uh an office chair with wheels in order
to get around and then i couldn't even
drive my own car home so you couldn't
even go back to your room
no no i went back to the room oh the
lodge is your room yeah like we were
like 10 10 15 people
sorry and uh yeah so i just i was in the
whole night i was just in a in a wheelie
chair and you haven't been skiing since
um
i went skiing one time since like two
years ago and i took lessons this time
wow unveil dude that's why i've never
been skiing or snowboarding and i don't
think i ever will go
it's it's
you know i think you guys are killed
when you're young right you get good
when you're like instinctual you know
you learn as a kid i don't know because
this kid's
whizzing by and the kids don't use ski
poles right and some of them i'm not
joking around i'm some of them almost
three years old i'm not joking around
they're three years old the skis are
like the size of my foot the only ski is
only that big and they
i mean they're just going they they
whizz past you let me ask you this do
you what is khalifa where's khalifa do
you think even
an experienced skier wouldn't have been
able to stop because of the ice
situation friends did they all did they
went down and waited for me they they
were laughing so what do you think i was
like
i was like crying laughing you know
because they were laughing and they
would photograph me and i was like no no
no because at that point they didn't
know they were like get up and i'm like
i can't oh before the medic got there i
thought my leg i i couldn't feel my leg
i couldn't feel my legs so your leg flew
off it was still it was so numb i didn't
know if it flew off or it was uh what a
compound fracture because it was
completely numb and i was like my leg my
leg and i reached down i was like
feeling for my leg and i just felt it
was swollen but i didn't know because i
was in a snow suit so i couldn't get it
open you know to see what had actually
happened i was feeling it and it felt
painful but i was like i swear to god i
don't know what i'm about to see oh my
god it was it was scary and i hate that
moment when you get injured and you have
to realize you ever been injured like
that
i got a head butt and
my whole forehead swelled over my eye
what what did you get head butted for
you was it head butter have you run in
your mouth
uh i was i ran into someone on a
basketball court and yeah i couldn't i
was so concussed it took like four
people to hold me back from driving my
car to the hospital oh yeah and i don't
remember days
wow
my grandfather um
my mom's dad since passed my grandpa
tony all right he had a uh
my whole life because it happened when
he was young in his on his forehead
picture the size of a golf ball okay
right and then picture like you can push
almost half the golf ball into your
skull so he had an indentation like
maybe on like maybe maybe a third of a
golf ball but the size of it right here
on his head permanently yeah it wasn't
like unsightly it kind of like just
blended in a little so when my mother
was little they were at a public pool
and my grandfather was in the pool and
someone jumped off the diving board and
when they came down the heel their foot
hit him in the head
literally fractured his skull
they had to he had to be rescued out of
the pool and then he lived until 96 and
his whole life he had a
dent in his huge dent in his freaking
head can you believe that yikes that's
why i've never cracked your head
uh i've hit my head i haven't like i
haven't like cracked anything proper i
haven't i've never it was my mom's big
yelling when we were little that was her
big thing she always said that except we
were jumping and playing she'd go stop
you're gonna crack your head yeah crack
my head all the time all the time yeah
jumping on the bed you're gonna crack
your head ronnie gonna crack your head
yeah she goes we call you crack your
head on the thermostat on the what the
hell's that thing the radiator the
radiator
oh really
crack your head and then also poke your
eye out with that you're going to poke
your eyes you're going to crack
says yeah or lollipop anything you're
going to crack your head open my mom
says it now and we're like mom no one
the the track record is impeccable i
don't know why you crack their head
nobody stop willing it yeah nobody's
cracking their head open one day
someone's gonna be there like a humpty
dumpty my mom's gonna be like
crack it
um yeah man i i i the only
pain i mean i've sprained both my ankles
a lot but as far as like pain pain pain
the worst pain i ever was in was when i
had mono you ever have mono oh thank
geez no dude mononucleosis shout out the
epstein-barr virus which is with you for
life shout out fatigue
it fatigues you for life yeah literally
my life is different since i had mono
the epstein-barr virus which did i heard
that from everyone who's had it you get
i'm tired all the time it's wild wild
dude it's just and there's nothing that
you can't correct it the absolute best
i've always heard right now why is it
called epstein-barr it's a fun name
though i have no idea
it is a fun jeffy steam bar pimpy can we
get something let's just hurry up
had a baby and it's the virus yeah
so about the fc bar i guess it's like
the guy who oh
i do have herpes wow it's a human herpes
virus
uh is a member of the herpes virus
family okay so remember the family it's
not it's not it's not the bad herpes but
right it's the cousin who almost made
something of himself right yeah
comparatively but i had it when i was
11. so and you and your fatigue now are
36. i'm exhausted right now from from
epstein-barr wow how'd you do were you
able to pinpoint who you got it from now
no no they said that it is known as the
kissing disease but i had not even
kissed a girl yet in my life then it was
from sharing water bottles
so so um uh
but that was because your lim my lymph
nodes i remember my lymph nodes being so
swollen that when i would spit it was
black like i was spitting charcoal
yeah and i didn't eat for 10 days or
something like that or eight days and
i'm starting to get lightheaded numb i
could only eat farina
and that's highly contagious right
you're not allowed in school for like a
month no no no and you know what
happened you're getting homeschooled for
a month no what happened was no
homeschool you know what happened is the
eighth grade i was in eighth grade so
i'm sorry i was thirteen eighth grade
class i got mono and i wanna say may
from september to may we had had a
perfect attendance record every student
perfect not one
the one and then i got mono what a bunch
of overachievers oh you ruined it for
everybody everybody the get well cost me
didn't come into about day five because
people were upset
when i didn't show up they were like
jesus even the none even even even uh
our teacher eighth grade teacher i
remember called home and was like is he
really he really is that sick huh
because i mean you know you want to make
the news you thought maybe you make new
york one
attendance for the year and i ruined it
and i still carry that guilt to this day
but so and i was so sick and then my mom
had had a a gout flare up so she
couldn't walk
so
so yeah and tt jerry was still in prison
so he couldn't help right so
so so we literally had my mom gal uh the
only possible mama you had two bangers
back to back the only positive thing i
remember coming from that is this 13 was
already 1998 is because of my mom having
the gout and me having mono my dad
wanted to do something nice for us
because you know my dad lived on staten
island we were in queens he got us cable
and we got cable television because i
had mono and she had gout so we got
cable tv
i remember being only basic channels
funny and then based off mono and gout
we and i remember you couldn't even no
one could even like flex on each other
no you couldn't complain i got mono she
was like what i've got
you should be like oh my god the guy
you're like i have mono oh yeah yeah so
we couldn't i remember couldn't do
anything so sick fever like you can't
imagine i remember like wishing being a
little kid being like wishing i would
die i remember like it was so bad but i
remember um the biggest thing with mono
is your spleen your spleen enlarges so i
couldn't play basketball for the rest of
the school year i couldn't i couldn't
the basketball was over and i couldn't
do it so i remember but but and you're
an only i'm an only child all right they
almost lost me to mono yeah i've seen
barn and what are you doing for 30 days
of epstein
i don't remember dude i remember i
remember eating carvel shadow car valley
remember i remember eating the farina i
remember my aunt janet coming up
wendy's being locked up that whole time
much like epstein much like that you're
probably looking at your sheets like
yeah yeah i was i know i was that
schoolyard was canceled like roseanne
wow like roseanne barker yeah yeah yeah
i i remember getting up one day and i
said remember get up getting up one day
and i said mom you look like an ape
remember that's what roseanne barnes
said when she got canceled oh she said
some woman looked like you know oh yeah
wasn't she i think she did i think she
was she was she on like some type of
percocet or something like that she's
something crazy oh like it was it no was
it like a luna lumines what's that what
it was
i know that thing that makes you go to
sleep uh ambient oh yeah people take
that and hallucinate right yeah yeah so
you'll take one
no but i would you know you know you
know who i heard has never taken amby
never even had a strawberry tom brady
why what what do you mean
what do you mean the strawberry he's
never eaten strawberries he's out with
he does what he says tom brady has said
publicly i've never done strawberry in
my life and but an ambien in the same
sentence the ambient part i made up oh
why isn't it strawberry i don't know
you won the super bowl though i know god
bless them god congratulations shout out
tom tampa bay bucks in tampa 43 years
old remiss fighting mentioned patrick
mahomes add hottie with the body yeah he
came in second place chiefs are really
trying to pick it up now yeah come on
chiefs we're rooting for you yep
uh strawberry you don't think that man
in all his riches and all his glory has
not had a chocolate dipped strawberry
google has tom brady had a strawberry is
he a lurch no i don't think he's never
had one and he doesn't eat any food then
in flames
he's he had never ingested one simply
because the strong smell bothered him oh
once he tried the fruit he wasn't
impressed he could taste a single bite
for 30 minutes and he really wasn't a
fan
well that is a real detailed paragraph
about tom dave brady tasting a
strawberry yeah there it is why does tom
pretty refuse to eat strawberries
oh my god there it is he won't eat
strawberries oh and tomatoes brady's
eliminated potatoes eggplant peppers and
tomatillos from his diet jeans greens
potatoes tomatoes rams pans chicken you
know this song no beans potatoes
tomatoes you know it no yeah
i don't know i don't want to not be able
to monetize
all right it's it's a i'll show it to
you name it it's a lady that is a
preacher lady who was preaching the
gospel and somebody sampled she's
awesome she's like well known and she
gets into it she was like thank god for
the greens beans potatoes tomatoes lamb
ramps and they put it to a beat yeah and
it became like a viral thing like years
ago it's amazing sometimes i used to
come out to it on stage
it's fun there it is baby all right
babes all right bubba's well listen
here's the good news at the end of
december from december 26 to the 31st me
and sally babes will be co-headlining so
you can come see us we'll be in texas
missouri and ohio go get a ticket
salvocano comedy.com right
salvacanocomedy.com christycomedy.com
check it out this is out before december
fourth and fifth at west palm beach
improv the 10th in boston at the
chevrolet theater and the 11th at the
borgata in atlantic city new jersey all
in december there you go baby and for me
and de sam's fourth and fifth phoenix
arizona 17th and 18th west palm beach uh
florida and then uh borgata is january
29th and the beacon theater february 5th
and we just put the win las vegas on
march 25th do the winning nice and then
homeless pimp is just the homeless pimp
and
send them he won't be with me in boston
yeah baby
it's gonna be yes oh yes that's just
this just didn't off the uh all the
presses derosa will be on the bill wow
joey rose's which is open now is it open
lower uh it's on rivington i believe yes
in the east lower east side joey rose's
it's a social club sandwich shop go
check it out there it is
check it out baby um all right this has
been hey listen it's been hey babe smell
your feet wait wait one more thing and
it's a big one
we are having our first in-house guest
next week yes first ever in-house guest
i can't believe i almost forgot to
mention this huge news for those of you
uh who used to like my old podcast
called what say you mr brian quinn will
be in the house uh next week the guest
everybody brian q quinn everybody qq
cute all right you've been asking for it
now you got it god bless there it is
that's the only guest you'll ever get
right
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings bae don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe hey